E aí
[Aplausos]
[Música]
o e-mail 61 o Russo Yuri Gagarin foi a
primeira pessoa aí no espaço ele disse
vejo a terra ela é azul
e foi essa afirmação que ficou matutando
na minha adolescência
afirmação é essa transmitida pelo meu
professor de Geografia na quinta série
um irmão Marista o irmão Renato
e tem o hábito de subir morros logo cedo
quando a paisagem lá embaixo está
coberta de nuvens e o céu em cima está
limpo e essa frase de Gagarin vem à
mente
É nesse grupo de Garen o debaixo
daquelas nuvens que vejo vivinho pessoas
que se interagem de alguma forma
tem que completei 30 anos de idade sai
em busca da resposta para essa pergunta
que surgiu como será esse mundo Azul
esse mundo das nuvens assim programei
minha vida criando oportunidades para
viajar seja no Brasil na América Latina
na Ásia na Europa na África e no oriente
médio para me Expor essas diferentes
sociedades culturas povos aprendendo o
máximo que podia convivendo com eles
frequentando os seus lares comendo suas
comidas
eu escolhi modo de viagem que oferecia
uma integração maior com o povo local
essas primeiras viagens foram e trem e
carona pé de camelo a mais longa delas
foi uma viagem de bicicleta uma volta ao
mundo em 747 Dias atravessando 30 países
e percorrendo 32 mil km
nela Descobri que esse é o melhor meio
de conhecer o mundo você viaja vacina
das pessoas
a
entrar em contato com rotina desses
povos a sensação de pertencimento que a
bicicleta proporciona é única
a bicicleta descobri que a gente não
precisa de muitas coisas ao nosso redor
que o essencial mesmo é ter sempre um
par de Havaianas
o e continua viajar com elas desde que
regressei dessa viagem em 2014 me
programo para viajar aproximadamente cem
Dias 90 a 100 dias por ano foi assim que
cria estilo de vida para ser um cidadão
Global um robô Pink
o que seria o que será um Global Finger
esse conceito partir lá do processo da
globalização
o Global fim quem o pensamento global
que é o risco chama esse cidadão global
é aquele cara que sai em busca do
conhecimento Através de outros povos e
mais do que isso buscar desenvolver
atitudes valores habilidades e ações
comprometidas com Esses povos claro
também com relação à igualdade à
democracia os direitos humanos EA
sustentabilidade serão Global fim que é
reconhecer que você faz parte das forças
o imóvel uma sociedade não existe o nós
e os outros parece fácil não é o
escritor português José Saramago
diz que o mais difícil não vai viver com
as pessoas e difícil mesmo é
compreendê-las e essa Compreensão é a
busca contínua da vida de um Global
finca
E aí
e tem uma história que ilustra muito bem
isso que eu nunca me esqueço quando pela
pedalava na Malásia uma van parou
enquanto eu consertava o pneu furado da
bicicleta era um grupo de indianos que
visitavam parentes que já viviam um
deles aparentando ser um tipo de um
líder daquele grupo disse a mim vocês lá
no Brasil são tão pobres assim não tem
dinheiro para o ônibus preciso sair aí
de bicicleta aí ele disse a minha sem
tome aqui vai de ônibus agora até o teu
próximo destino
me deu o dinheiro equivalente r$ 200
hoje porém eu não continuar de ônibus
continue pedalando
e esse é um exemplo E quanto a visão
sobre a pobreza o sucesso EA felicidade
pode ser algo muito relativo
Algum cara e ficar aqueles que
nacionalidades desiguais quanto mais
igual desigual uma sociedade mais
explícita a esse pensamento
trazendo isso para academia é a metáfora
das camadas de cebola do professor Dr
Mike Edgar China essa teoria é muito
visado os estudos e cultura
organizacional isso e culturalmente
somos como uma casca de cebola
é uma cebola na verdade né tirando essas
várias camadas que formam os seus Anéis
chega ao ponto essencial o centro que
ali está os nossos valores as nossas
regras nossos tabus questões que estão
inseridas naquela sociedade né são
incontestáveis eu mesmo
são exemplos disso eu posso ser um
tremendo de um Global Finger mas no
fundo sempre serei um cidadão
jaraguaense
e por isso pode interações que observava
e das quais participavam por é afora
pelo mundo
e sempre comparei os que vivenciam na
minha cidade
como as pessoas de se dirigir a uma
outra
como compartilho Às vezes o trânsito um
lugar da bicicleta nessa dinâmica os
preconceitos e todos nós temos
como é o cuidado com o meio ambiente e
ao mesmo tempo eu também amei
valorizando com obstáculos os problemas
que apresentavam a minha cidade né e
procurava toda hora esse momento uma
conexão com que eu via por aí
bom e sabe que tem uma coisa muito
interessante que então nas cidades dos
continentes as cidades menores nem todos
os cantinhos poderá fazer as menores em
algo em comum elas não gostam muito
diferente o professor gera Diamond
aniversário da Califórnia fala muitos
tipos de intercâmbio ao longo de suas
obras o pato o Brasil é um país não é
muito chegado a diferente não é conforme
dados do IBGE não chegar um por cento
estrangeiros e vive no Brasil São Paulo
que a nossa Metrópole tem apenas dois
por cento de estrangeiros
só por um comparativo
conforme a reportagem da revista Forbes
o estado da Califórnia por exemplo
possuem cinco das cidades dos Estados
Unidos com maior número de estrangeiros
isso não percentual aí ao redor de 30 40
porcento
e começa a integração internacional
brasileiro é baixa a gente acaba tendo
uma sociedade mais provinciana
Ah e quanto mais aberto uma sociedade
quanto maior a sua interação com o mundo
mas Google Finger é o seu povo
é como se pode ver alguns países por
exemplo o Nepal EA Tailândia Eles
criaram uma interessante interseção
entre o que vem eu do ocidente com as
suas raízes orientais um outro exemplo
no ocidente a Holanda
conforme escritor Umberto Eco ele disse
que é o melhor país do mundo para se
viver né porque um país muito aberto as
diferenças mas o que podemos fazer para
que sejamos Global thinkers O que
podemos fazer a partir disso
a mudar a mentalidade
os ingleses passaram por esse processo
no seu período de colonização em 1920 a
Inglaterra de tinha 25 porcento
território de todo o globo
as
músicas foram maior Império se tem na
história Então como Aquele caso do
Senhor indiano que achou que eu viajava
de bicicleta porque não tinha dinheiro
para pagar o ônibus
temos que ter em mente que essa visão é
algo construído algo histórico algo
social essa visão se baseia é o nosso
centro que está embaixo das camadas de
cebola
mas também podemos mudar um pouco disso
Nós podemos
ser com o nosso passado né e deixar isso
para o passado em si e não pode podemos
mudar o nosso futuro perante é isso
podemos escolher um outro caminho claro
que esse ano nossas certezas com isso
também não estou pedindo para que
mudamos o nosso estilo de vida
vendemos nossas coisas né temos uma vida
humilde e ter uma vida nova Não isso não
tem também nada a ver com rouba um
Finger da mesma forma não é preciso
pisar em vários países para entender a
importância os valores e outras culturas
e Principalmente nesse mundo nesse mundo
atual um tanto acesso à informação o que
estou pedindo é tenhamos empatia é se
interessa e pelo outro né respondo as
diversidades se engaje com algo coletivo
se abra ao desconhecido
Aristóteles disse que nós somos seres
curiosos
Particularmente eu acredito que a
curiosidade que me move o ser E aí
a todos os dias quando Acordamos tem uma
nova chance de imaginar a terra azul de
Garen o mergulhar nos as nuvens sobre o
monte vamos ver o mundo as diferenças
como Pontes ou portões não como
obstáculos assim depois se descobre que
a clínica é diferente acaba sendo igual
Muito obrigado
E aí
[Aplausos]
[Música]